internal revenue service been around
since the 1862. looks like uh what's his
name abe lincoln created it probably to
fund the war fascist in 1914 there was
like a revolution within the internal
revenue service oddly right after they
formed the federal reserve 1914 or right
then when they were forming it and they
created the new income tax
you guys know i would love to hear from
you guys about the history of the irs
yeah so well well the income tax so all
of this stuff right was under the
woodrow wilson administration and yes
it's certainly not a coincidence right
that right after the year after they
created the federal reserve well then
it's like okay well if this fed's going
to lend us our own money that we will
now owe them back with interest well
we're going to need a little bit of a uh
of
a stream of money coming in and the way
the income tax was sold uh was that it
was only going to uh apply to the top
top one percent of people they sold this
as a this was during the progressive era
as it was known and they sold this as a
progressive measure so this is don't
even work listen this is going to be
something that's going to be for the fat
cats the robber barons it's going to be
like two percent of their income like
we're going to take that and then we'll
share it around with everybody and the
rest of us will all be wealthier this is
not going to apply to your average
working joe of course
they won't stop saying the same thing
over and over again they're still to
this day they still use the same but at
the time it was like okay so that's how
they got the support and that's how they
got so we got the federal reserve in
play we got uh the income tax in play
and three years later we're in a world
war
i mean you know what federal reserve
really is doing it's just their legal
way of reaching into your bank account
and taking your money that's right
that's all they do right so as the great
ron paul happy birthday again used to
always say right the the real tax is
spending the real tax is government
spending because when government spends
money what can they do well all they can
do is they can either tax the money from
you or they can borrow the money which
is a promise to tax you in the future or
they can print the money which is in
effect just taxing you right now or a
little bit in the future because it's
just robbing the value of your dollar so
when government spends a dollar they've
stolen a dollar from you forget taxation
is theft government spending is theft
and the reason the like so when we got
into world war one was it 1917 we got
into world war one okay so just a few
years after this then well i know the
plan for the income tax was just to be
for the top one percent and you weren't
gonna but crisis
world war
so now everybody's gonna have to pay
taxes and we're gonna have to increase
the rates and then you know the the
crisis will be over soon except then we
have a great depression that's another
crisis we have the second world war
that's another crisis and then oh by the
way this is just permanent government
policy
there is a there is a fee
for producing something that you are now
not only is there a fee for you having a
job and being a productive member of
society but you lose any semblance of
fifth amendment rights to not
incriminate yourself you now have to
incriminate yourself every year to the
federal government because you are
already presumed guilty presumed a
criminal by your own government for the
crime of being a productive member of
society yeah and and what's funny about
that is they're supposed to issue a
receipt on what your taxes go for and of
course you know you're under penalty if
you don't comply and there's absolutely
no accountability for them if they don't
so
and what you were saying as far as
income taxes were never supposed to be
for the average wage earner you know and
then you also pointed out earlier um
the the
suspending of gold was supposed to be
temporary it's just that it's that
classic uh harry brown quote if there's
nothing more permanent than a temporary
uh government program yeah so let them
have a little power they're not giving
it back easy what ends up happening when
they start this is it's just for the
rich it's no big deal it won't affect
you well it's an emergency so everyone's
going to pitch in
then it's well the emergency we got
another emergency well now it's another
world war and then by the time it's the
crisis are finally calming down and you
come out and say okay you're appealing
this they'll be repealing what yeah well
the taxes what do you mean the taxes
have always been there well right
exactly think about a problem with
anything think about euro far right
right so 10 years ago nine years ago we
killed osama bin laden just just now
we're pulling out of the war in
afghanistan so is it like okay well
goodbye tsa
no tsa ain't going nowhere man that's
the norm now you're used to that don't
ever believe the the lesson here is
don't ever believe there are 15 days to
flatten the curve on anything because
it's never that it's never temporary
afghanistan was another one it was never
supposed to be this
broad war on terrorism or this 20-year
thing oh yeah supposed to be to go and
get the terrorists that knocked down the
twin towers if you look at the auma i
mean the language of it uh was
just to go get the people who knocked
down the twin towers that was the the
authorization i'm sorry yes
mf the authorization of uh military
force so they didn't authorization
authorization yeah they didn't declare
war they they declared uh military force
for a constrained mission which was to
go get bin laden and the terrorists and
that's why you know ron paul actually
voted for that because that what is what
is what it was supposed to be and then
he he also tried to issue letters of
marquee and reprisal to basically hire
mercenaries to to help get these named
people bin laden his lieutenants but you
know and that didn't happen and then
they they took that inch and ran about
40 50 miles with it 20 years with it
yeah and and it should be uh like noted
that look they had osama bin laden in i
think even their november or december of
2001 when they had him pinned in tora
bora and they could have killed osama
bin laden and they they had forces over
in
kabul fighting the taliban they had
forces in the north green berets in the
north that they didn't even call into
the action the forces on the ground were
saying we need reinforcements right here
we've got osama bin laden we could have
killed osama bin laden in late 2001 been
done with the whole thing called off the
entire terror war and man what a better
world we're living in if that's what we
do and instead they allowed
whether intentionally or unintentionally
and i really
i'm just speculating but i lean toward
intentionally on this they allowed him
to escape into pakistan because i'll
tell you
look
there's no question that the the a lot
of the people the forces on the ground
were like there's no we can block off
the [ __ ]
the pakistan border right now and we can
get bin laden this is easy if you just
send us the reinforcements and they had
specifically the bush administration had
not declared war on al qaeda they had
not declared war on the people who did 9
11. they had not even declared war on
afghanistan they declared war on
terrorism on terror and they had already
had plans to go into iraq on the
pretense that he was working with osama
bin laden now if you kill osama bin
laden in december 2001
what really is the motivation to go into
iraq and all of these other wars you
probably lose it but if he's still out
there and he could be working with other
people and he could be plotting these
things then you've got 20 years of war
you think if hillary would have won we'd
be in iran
i don't know um i think certainly it it
you wouldn't have had the deal the the
or i'm sorry if hillary had one i'm
thinking 2008 you're thinking you're
talking 2016. right so if hillary had
one in 2016 i i think it's likely she
would have wanted to push for it the
problem with the warren in iran is that
no matter how many of the um
blood-soaked monster neo-cons and i
include hillary clinton in that list
want a war with iran the actual
logistics of doing it are so bad that
many people in the military are like
look we just can't do a war with iran
because iran is a more serious adversary
than any of the countries we've picked
on in the middle east right now they
will they will slaughter uh u.s military
members all around i want i want to i
want to show people something real quick
we have this map so you can understand a
lot of people don't know the geography
iraq is just to the west of iran and
afghanistan is to the east i don't
believe it was a coincidence we said
iraq and afghanistan what was in the
middle and what did john bolton say he
wanted to do he said this time next year
we will be celebrating victory in tehran
yeah we had a pincer attack on iran but
iran is not iraq or afghanistan it is a
mountainous very well populated armed
strong nation yeah but they've wanted to
go after iran for a long time did you oh
no question did you ever see that video
from i think it was around 2003 five you
know fact check me on that but of uh
general wesley clark
where he was saying
prior to uh them going into iraq they
were telling him we're going into iraq
and then the plan after that is to go
into venezuela and ultimately iran and
he named like four or five countries
seven countries he also included syria
in that list i think sudan was in the
list as well yeah no it didn't play out
exactly like the plan that he mentioned
but there was certainly something to
that and you watch that what real what
did happen after uh uh 9 11 was wars all
throughout the middle east i mean wars
in you know iraq afghanistan somalia
pakistan libya
syria
with guadalupe yeah well they they yeah
but not a you know not a war like we had
in these countries central banks and all
these countries
they want to get in there install the
central banking system get out and then
we won we've unified the world through
economics which goes back to what we
were talking about before is that one of
the primary weapon here is debt
like like students debt businesses with
the lockdowns debt you know credit card
debt like everything is debt and and and
they're getting us to to keep feeding
them with our productivity by
ensnaring us in debt yeah for sure
and that's i'll just say and don't buy
listen don't buy their propaganda about
this whole thing in afghanistan and i
hope that people can can see through it
like i'm not saying this isn't kind of
ugly joe biden's pull you know withdraw
from afghanistan and that there's not
some like ugly aspects of it but just
like take a step back zoom out and peep
game you know what i mean like see
what's going on here when cnn is saying
this is a nightmare oh this is a tragedy
joe biden oh what if what has he done
i'm kind of like wait a minute but
here's what drives me crazy right is
that i see these people like like right
winger types who like i agree with on
some stuff not on others but i see i see
uh charlie curt tweeted something i
think it was him he tweeted something
where he goes you know cnn saying
something and they go
he takes it as a dig on biden he goes
man when you've lost cnn you're really
doing bad it's like no charlie kirk you
got this game all wrong man why did he
lose cnn
because he ended a freaking war
that's why he lost cnn did obama lose
cnn when he destroyed libya oh no that
wasn't a problem see all of a sudden the
corporate press has these these deep
passionate humanitarian impulses all of
a sudden there's this moral outrage
about the innocent people in afghanistan
we have we have started wars in about
six or seven different countries that
have led to millions of innocent people
being slaughtered not a peep out of the
corporate press not a peep as in yemen
babies are vomiting to death
by the hundreds of thousands because of
the us-backed saudi war in yemen not a
peep out of the corporate press but all
of a sudden they're the humanitarians
the one time we end the war and when was
the other time they became big
humanitarians when donald trump tried to
end the war in syria who the kurds what
about the kurds see through this man do
you remember what the media said when
trump fired 59 tomahawk missiles into
syria it's presidential exactly
beautiful is this the time trump has
become a president that's right so so
don't they all cheer the assassination
of salamani that's right yeah don't it
maybe it's just a wild coincidence that
every time it's within the
military-industrial complex's interests
the corporate press becomes humanitarian
and when it's in their interests they
look the other way and don't care so
that's all i'm saying
listen by the way for anyone out there
joe biden is the architect the architect
architect of some of the worst policies
in modern american history he is an evil
person and he is very responsible
directly for the war on terrorism
particularly the war in iraq under
george w bush that he championed and
voted for okay and he's also just an
embarrassing
like elderly you know incompetent person
but
this is this is not what it appears to
be thanks for checking out this clip
from the tim cast irl podcast if you
want to see the full show come back to
this channel youtube.com tim cast irl
monday through friday at 8pm where you
can leave comments and super chat and we
actually will read your comments on the
show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else go to timcast.com
become a member and we even have full
bonus episodes thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time